we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman if you're trying to quit
smoking or vaping check out lucy which
is a nicotine gum developed by
caltech scientists they'll ship it right
to your door and you can save
twenty percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman nebia is a
revolutionary showerhead that saves you
money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water
that's way more powerful than what you
get with other shower heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
so after months and months and months
and months and months seven months
lawmakers have finally agreed to a
second
coronavirus stimulus and they have not
yet voted on it they've agreed on it
the house and senate still need to vote
on it but in this story i'll tell you
everything that you might be getting and
also what big business is getting
and what nobody's getting which is very
very important um
sadly this is mostly too little too late
like if you want to just
click off and go to a different story
it's mostly too little too late and
you'll see why
momentarily uh but let's dig into it
this the the package in total is 900
billion dollars
it will include 600 payments to adults
earning up to 75 000
with the possibility of an additional
600 per dependent child
living at home although the language and
the specifics on that
may still change it's not completely
clear
restarted restarted enhanced
unemployment will be in place
for 300 per week for 11 weeks remember
the original enhanced unemployment was
600 a week this will be
300 a week there will be 284 billion
dollars
for businesses the ppp program will be
restarted
there will be expanded eligibility uh
for non-profits
newspapers radio and tv broadcasters
15 billion for performance venues and
independent movie theaters which are
essentially
shut down in total uh save some rare
examples that have figured out how to do
sort of uh like mask required everybody
gets tested on the way in
types of things there will be money for
testing and tracing
82 billion dollars for colleges and
schools which many people have an issue
with
uh the the idea of some of these largely
well-endowed schools uh getting money
when they don't even really need to be
charging tuition
they could pay for everybody's tuition
with the interest on their endowments
that's a problem for some 13 billion
dollars for nutritional assistance 7
billion
for broadband access 25 billion for
rental assistance
and an extended eviction moratorium so
basically
it's too little too late and the devil
is in the details with a lot of these
line items for example
just to pick one seven billion dollars
for broadband support
how exactly does that work is it just a
cash grab
for isps is it actually reimbursements
for people who sign up for internet
service what how is that that all
it's all in the in the details because
these programs can either be beneficial
or slush funds for big corporations or
both admittedly it can be it can be both
now is it better than nothing well yeah
of course of course uh
with the caveat that sometimes doing
something crappy
is used as an excuse to not do anything
else so
if i have a gunshot wound and you hand
me a band-aid
is the band-aid better than nothing if
more help is coming well yeah it might
be the band-aid might do something for
me
for two minutes until we get real
treatment
but if handing me the band-aid is all we
do well then i'm going to be screwed
and it's been seven months since the
last uh
stimulus package people are getting half
the cash payment
and half the enhanced unemployment and
now
i i've been getting voicemails over the
weekend from people
who seem to think the reason i'm i did a
segment last week advocating for more
there's people who seem to think i'm
advocating for more so that i will get
more of something i i i don't even know
that i need to do this but i will
mention
that i am getting nothing i got nothing
last time
and neither did my business i'm getting
nothing this time
and neither is my business i'm not
arguing for even a single
dollar for myself i'm getting zero
either way so
the it's half the benefits for people as
as the first time half the money is the
first time
uh and then the unemployment benefits
are
half as big and they last for only 11
weeks about three months so
this all counts on a dramatically strong
recovery that will be in full swing
by march and things should be better by
then
as it starts getting warmer again and
people start being
vaccinated at a higher rate but
expecting anything
approaching a full recovery by by three
months from now seems very silly
uh some industries won't be fully
recovered for years it is believed
a huge portion of small businesses are
never reopening people are making
zero right now so much like i said
before this was put together
uh uh you know if you're really
struggling 600
isn't going to do much for you at all
it's been seven months you get 600 bucks
it's not enough for a month's rent in
almost any part of the country
the unemployment payments won't be
retroactive so if you've been out of a
job for the last
several months um that that's just gone
too bad it's not retroactive and there
are some on the right who are saying you
should be grateful that you got anything
the government doesn't owe you anything
600
is 600 more than the government owes you
well the the idea of owing
is sort of strange but considered that
the government allowed the pandemic
to get this bad in the first place one
of the worst responses
in the world from the trump
administration and now it's everyone
else who should be grateful that they'll
get 600 bucks
which is of course paid out of our own
tax money remember
despite it being the government's fault
that this got so bad
in the first place and had the
government handled this properly
in a better way we wouldn't even need
the degree of stimulus that's now needed
and then on the tail end of this
just the last thought that i have on
this calling it a rescue package is
almost laughable
but there is some aspect of this that
makes me wonder
is mitch mcconnell and are republicans
all of a sudden ready to get this done
quickly
because they believe it will help kelly
leffler and david perdue in georgia and
what i mean by that is
we've had the 2020 election trump lost
biden won
okay uh democrats retained control of
the house
albeit by a smaller margin than they had
after the 2018 election
but control of the senate is still a
question mark control of the senate
senate is still up for grabs
and it will depend on these two runoff
elections on january 5th in georgia
is this an attempt to say hey look
lefler and purdue delivered
600 bucks to you and more unemployment
money even to many vote
voters in georgia republican georgia
voters who don't even think the
government should be giving people
anything
is that part of the calculation here i
don't know
uh that that you know with mitch
mcconnell it's
the answer is it's likely so it's been
agreed upon
it's not yet been voted on will follow
the the process
up to actually being approved if it will
be and then of course who knows how many
weeks or months it would be until people
actually get any money
if you really want to hear about just
the worst of the worst of the left you
have to hear about what's happening
over the last 72 hours now last week i
got a phone call during live calls on
last
friday show from a viewer asking me what
do i think about the aoc
versus jimmy dore debate and when the
caller asked me about it i had no idea
what it was about
and the caller explained to me very very
politely the debate is that a youtuber
named jimmy dore
thinks that the squad should hold their
votes for nancy pelosi's
uh speaker of speakership hostage
unless nancy pelosi is willing to hold a
vote in the house for medicare for all
and when the caller brought it up i
hadn't heard about it at the time
it started on twitter the previous
weekend i don't
watch the show that the caller mentioned
i wasn't on twitter over that weekend so
i had no idea
i have now learned about it thanks to
the caller
and the same thing continued to explode
this weekend where now
even aoc apparently isn't progressive
enough aoc is
failing progressive purity tests because
she's
unsure about the value of holding her
vote hostage for a medicare for all vote
in the house she's
questioning whether that would really do
anything for people with acute
needs right now now the funny thing
about all of them
there's a bunch of funny things and some
sad things and some infuriating things
one of the funny things about this is
that for the last several years
when it comes to aoc i've mostly been
attacked
for being too critical of aoc and for
not being deferential enough
to any of aoc's notions when i found
that she lacked knowledge or pragmatism
in one place or another
i would mention it people would be
furious with me now aoc
is actually the one being pragmatic and
the so-called populist left
has turned on her and what's really
bonkers is that the populist left
seems more angry with aoc than they are
with donald trump
when trump is going lunatic
authoritarian uh and had an
oval office meeting over the weekend
about whether he should declare martial
law if he even could
whether he should seize voting machines
by force because he lost an election and
he can't admit it
but the populace left on twitter is
focused on aoc now in fact
i actually said about seven to eight
months after aoc was sworn in you know
guys i have to tell you
i am pleased that aoc's political
instincts are maturing
since she's gotten into congress her
political instincts
improved dramatically from the campaign
aoc
to when she was actually in office her
pragmatism
and her understanding of how politics
works improved dramatically
and now if you said to me right now what
is the most important thing to keep in
mind about this issue
what is the most instructive possible
takeaway
about this spat that is taking place
within the left
mostly on twitter and reddit well
there's actually a few takeaways number
one
there is nothing wrong with uh now i
want people to take out a notepad and
make a note of what i'm about to say
and don't email me about it okay because
i'm i'm telling you right now
there's nothing wrong with uh people on
the left criticizing others on the left
nothing wrong with them there's nothing
wrong with
uh progressives primary centrist or
corporate democrats that should be
that's great that should be encouraged
okay great
there's nothing wrong with any of those
things at a structural level
but the takeaways here are number one
the so-called populist left on twitter
and reddit represents a small
but very vocal internet enclave
that does not connect to most of what's
happening
in the real world now we learned this
sadly it was a rude awakening
during the democratic primary how could
bernie possibly have lost
he had so much energy he had the best
streams
he had the best rallies if you spent
time on twitter and read it
it looked like bernie couldn't possibly
have lost that primary
but he lost the primary by millions of
votes because most of the electorate and
the democratic party voters
are not in the internet populist left
space
it's not a value judgment it's an
evaluation of fact
and if we don't get it it'll continue to
go this way
and this is the exact same thing if
you're a factory worker dad
who's trying to figure out how to put
food on your family's table
for your two kids while continuing to
work during a pandemic
and your employer might have to lay off
10 of the workforce due to the pandemic
and you might be in that 10
laid off do you need a list of the
members of congress who support medicare
for all right now
particularly absent any actual credible
way to get it passed as we are about to
get a new congress seated
i'm not saying the dad doesn't care
about medicaid medicare for all
i'm not saying that dad wouldn't benefit
from medicare for all i'm saying
does anyone outside of these online
spaces think that what is effectively a
naughty and nice list
in a congress that has two weeks left
before
some some leave and some new people get
sworn in that's what that dad cares
about
or imagine a business owner in houston
who sells
wedding dresses okay and has seen their
business decimated due to this
due to the pandemic they're waiting on a
second stimulus they're wondering
when will people go back to weddings
that business owner
is waiting on a vote on medicare for all
which there is not even support
for in the senate anyway and which joe
biden didn't run on what
just to have a list of people to primary
so the point
isn't that there's no place for such a
vote or that it shouldn't be done
i'm fine with it but attacking aoc
now because she's far more realistic
about how politics works than much of
the populist left
when we're we're trying to get a second
stimulus it looks like we're going to
get a pathetic one
uh and we have so many other issues
going on and again the
the president is talking about martial
law and seizing voting machines
the the point is aoc now is not left
enough she's not passed the progressive
purity test
it's another example of the left eating
itself if these people are even on the
left i'm not sure and that's what's
tricky about populist rhetoric
it sounds very similar on the left and
right until you get to the solutions
some of the so-called populist left now
attacking
aoc is praising tulsi gabbard
whose recent ideas on trans people and
abortion
don't look like anything i recognize as
being part of the left so
maybe the issue and i'm thinking out
loud here maybe the issue is that some
of these people aren't really leftists
they seem more into what tucker carlson
is proposing than what we see from aoc
now again there are people who say i'm
not really on the left
so starting to to say well this person
is not really what they claim to be
i i get that it's fraught and that it's
problematic and my point again just to
restate it
is not that the left shouldn't criticize
the left when the left fails to be
left as i've done many times um but
uh the the real issue here is that it
seems to be a complete
loss of the plot for lack of a better
term
um trump considering martial law and
people are saying
aoc being unwilling to do something that
will make no political difference anyway
makes her enemy number one this is how
the left keeps losing i want the left to
win i don't think this is the path
to victory um let me know what you think
i would love to hear from you remember
that on january
1st we will be doing a one day
membership special the idea is to set
the one-day record for new memberships
as we've speculated my immoral illegal
membership specials could be clamped
down on by the incoming biden
administration so you got to get those
memberships before biden is sworn
in that's that's a joke everybody relax
it's we're just kidding around
uh but in all seriousness on january 1st
we'll send out an email blast
with a monstrous membership special if
you want to be notified about it just
get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com
and let me know what you think about
this entire aoc thing uh you can find me
on twitter
at d pacman the david pakman show at
[Music]
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinkist
and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember we're mostly funded by
memberships people who just go to
joinpackman.com
and sign up it's quick it's easy you get
the daily bonus show just for our paid
members
and it just feels good you can use the
coupon code fresh start
to get 70 off your choice of membership
pick anyone you like at joinpacman.com
there's simply no way to tell you how
insane this story is
without screaming and going crazy but
i'm going to try to do it while while
sort of remaining calm if if it's
possible
donald trump the president of the united
states who
lost the november election by a lot to
joe biden and is scheduled to leave the
white house in a month
had a meeting at the white house this
weekend where he discussed with lawyers
declaring martial law and forcibly
seizing voting machines see how calmly i
said that
the calmness with which i said it has no
connection whatsoever to the complete
and utter insanity and depravity of the
situation
and considering martial law isn't the
only thing
that donald trump did during this
meeting trump
is considering naming that complete nut
lawyer
sydney powell she's the conspiracy
theorist attorney
who trump said just weeks ago has
nothing to do with anything he's doing
trump is considering naming her special
counsel
to oversee a supposed voter fraud
investigation this is the same woman who
said that there's a venezuelan plot
also involving antifa george soros
and a guy named eric coomer to steal the
election
trump is considering naming her special
counsel
trump and rudy giuliani want the
department of homeland security to
seize voting machines to examine them
and some of donald trump's lawyers and
if chief of staff
his chief of staff said you know you
actually can't do that
now at one point in this meeting when
people were telling trump
the things you want to do are against
the law
sydney powell reportedly started
chastising them saying that they were
quitters
they were unwilling to do what needed to
be done when donald trump was told
you know department of homeland security
they can't just go and seize voting
machines legally from the states
trump suggested what if i sign an
executive order to seize the voting
machines which trump's lawyer pat
cipollone
said yeah we also can't do that and then
yes donald trump asked the team about
imposing martial law
as suggested previously recently by
donald trump's indicted
and later pardoned former national
security adviser michael flynn who
during a recent appearance on newsmax
said trump should declare
martial law so this is where we are
right now
this is now the insane situation
in which we find ourselves the president
is actually thinking
and saying out loud to lawyers what if i
impose martial law to avoid having to
admit
that i lost the election in order to try
to steal it
and meanwhile the trump administration
is saying that it's bad that a biden
advisor used a bad word last week
can you can you imagine everything is
backwards trump
wants to look at seizing voting machines
people around trump are telling him bad
idea it's illegal
and trump considers naming the woman
they recently said
had nothing to do with them to oversee
all of this and you know what's really
insane
when word of this and other harebrained
plans
uh previously have leaked a bunch of
trump's followers
react uh and they say oh you know this
is
uh this this is to they don't instead of
saying
wow that's too far that this even this i
voted for trump but even this is too
much
they react by saying you know if trump
is thinking of doing this
it must be part of some brilliant plan
because trump always has something up
his sleeve trump
he must be playing 4d chess remember
benghazi
and the 11 congressional hearings that
were held to look at what crimes hillary
committed
which turned out to be none there have
been no
hearings over trump's complete
mishandling of the pandemic
in which more than 300 thousand
americans have died and there is no
discussion at least right now
about wait a second if we had 11
hearings over benghazi
shouldn't we be looking into what the
president is doing
talking about martial law seizing voting
machines and a special counsel
to investigate non-existent voter fraud
that doesn't deserve an investigation
the last month that we have to go here
at this point i guess it's 29
30 days this last month is not going to
be calm and boring
it's going to be off the rails
outrageous that's very clear
and on the tail end of this remember as
donald trump is doing this
much of the populist left is talking
about how
aoc might not meet their progressive
purity tests
that's what the left spent their weekend
on as trump is talking about martial law
in the oval office so
earlier in the show we already talked
about that we'll follow up on that
and we will also keep an eye on what
what is happening in the oval office
trump doesn't go out publicly
he's not been seen for uh i don't even
know weeks now
uh but he's talking about this stuff in
the oval office we'll continue to follow
it
a quick story about donald trump's press
secretary and
senior adviser to the trump campaign
kaylee mcinanni
has now entered a complete and total
fantasy world where up is down
day is night and i guess stupid is smart
now
in the real world where i believe most
of you live
joe biden won the election with the
votes he garnered on november 3rd
and then those votes translated
into electoral votes last monday
december 14th
when electors in all 50 states met in
accordance
with the results in each state casting
their electoral votes
for joe biden to have 306 electoral
votes
that's the process by which joe biden
won
in kaylee mcinanny's alternate universe
listen to what she came up with what is
the update now
that we're at this late date in terms of
the challenges and other states and
investigations that are ongoing
yeah there's still ongoing litigation in
arizona there are a few other appeal
options
in nevada and elsewhere so the
president's litigation is ongoing
make no mistake also in the four states
that
we saw a lot of problems in with those
big metro areas the only metro areas
where joe biden beat hillary clinton
ironically
in those states there has been an
alternate slate of electors voted upon
that congress will decide
in january so we will see what happens
ongoing litigation
this president's a fighter he's not
giving up he will fight for the
forgotten men
so she tells fox news propagandist sean
hannity
that not only is there litigation going
on but
alternate electors voted on december
14th as well even in states where joe
biden
officially won and officially got
electoral votes
if republicans believe trump really won
that state
a second slate of republican electors
also voted for trump
and as far as kaylee wants you to
believe a court
is going to decide or mike pence will
decide on january 6th
which electors to count all right it
looks like biden won and democratic
electors voted for biden
but mike pence could choose to recognize
an alternate slate of republican
electors this is a grift
this is a griff that's it some of you
may have actually heard that
there were such alternate electors in
some states michigan pennsylvania some
other states
it's not untrue if you don't understand
what it means to be an elector
it it is untrue because these so-called
al alternate electors aren't actually
electors in any legal sense
so what happened was that a bunch of
republicans
appointed themselves alternate electors
it's a term that doesn't exist there's
no such thing as an alternate elector
it's not like a jury where you have 12
people on the jury and two
alternate jurors who listen to the
evidence and they're ready
if a juror should fall ill no
they did nothing of legal meaning they
appointed themselves electors
and they cast votes for trump in a
meaningless unofficial exercise
mike pence in the joint session on
january 6th
he simply counts electoral votes mike
pence doesn't get to say well
i've got 16 democratic electoral votes
from georgia
and 16 republican electoral votes let me
choose which ones to accept
it doesn't work that way it's a fantasy
world
and kaylee is spreading this fantasy on
fox news
and it probably does lead to trumpists
continuing to donate cash to trump but
it's
fake these electors are electors only in
the sense that i could call up my high
school classmates and say guys
let's get together and cast alternate
votes as electors
what it's it's meaningless guys let's
get together and then
mike pence or the supreme court will
decide do they count
those electors or do they count us it's
fake
it's absurd it's ridiculous and people
are actually being scammed out of money
if they believe it thinking let's keep
donating because they're gonna
fight up up until i guess the supreme
court
to try to get these alternate electors
votes counted it's just fake
you're falling for something that
doesn't exist um
maybe i shouldn't be that worried about
trumpists getting scammed
but i want to make sure it's clear that
this is a complete and total fantasy
we'll have more about this on our
instagram page you can find the show on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
you can find me on instagram
david.pakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen cinnamon and
pomegranate they also have lozenges
which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20 percent off when you use
the coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical
welcome back to the david pakman show
so this really has to be seen to be
believed uh
fox host lou dobbs has been one of the
major
nodes of spreading bogus election fraud
claims since november 3rd he's done
everything from
interview that wacky lawyer sidney
powell to interviewing supposed
witnesses of voter fraud who
signed affidavits he's been full on with
this thing
repeating and allowing the promotion of
completely baseless claims about
companies
like dominion voting and smartmatic and
others he's really been full on with
this thing
and then suddenly a couple of days ago
lou dobbs aired a fact check
that debunked his own election
conspiracy theories
what on earth is going on and what's
going on is fascinating it turns out
that smartmatic which is one of the
companies that makes
voting machines about which lou dobbs
has been spreading this information
smartmatic wrote a legal demand letter
to fox news
uh newsmax and oan threatening legal
action if they don't retract their
completely bogus claims about smartmatic
and the letter
actually quotes lou dobbs it quotes
fox host maria bartoromo and others who
simply
will not stop making insane claims about
voter fraud
and it looks like fox lawyers decided
that the letters had some teeth
because lou dobbs ended up airing the
following segment
which please understand this key part
this
segment debunks the lies lou
himself was telling over the last five
weeks
and lou just looks absolutely miserable
introducing this segment and what's
fascinating
is that this is clearly a pre-produced
segment
meant specifically to get fox news out
of legal hot water
the questions are asked in voiceover
they're all very carefully worded
it's stunning to watch this take a look
lots of opinions about the integrity of
the election the irregularities of
mail-in
voting of election voting machines and
voting software
one of the companies is smartmatic and
we reached out to one of the leading
authorities on open source software for
elections
eddie perez for his insight and views
eddie is the global director of tech
development
at the open source election technology
institute
we asked him for his assessment of
smartmatic and recent claims
about the company have you seen any
evidence that smartmatic software was
used to flip votes anywhere in the u.s
in this election i have not seen any
evidence that smartmatic software was
used to
uh delete change alter anything related
to vote tabulation
smartmatic says its software was never
used outside of la county in 2020.
do you know whether or not that's true
that is my understanding
smartmatic functioned as the contract
manufacturer
for the los angeles county voting system
and that was a customized system that
was effectively built to the county's
order
i am not aware of them having any other
direct customers relationships with
election officials in the united states
what about smartmatic and dominion do
you know if they're related
whether one owns the other whether
dominion uses smartmatic software
both dominion and smartmatic have
individually and respectively put out
a very clear statements from their
corporate headquarters
each of them indicating they are
independent companies they are not
related to each other
it is my understanding that neither one
of them has an ownership stake in the
other
or anything like that so that directly
debunks the things
that lou dobbs and his guests have been
claiming
including as an example that there's
some kind of nefarious link
between smartmatic and dominion voting
systems
and then at the end of this segment they
just cut directly to commercial
no explanation no commentary from lou
dobbs
totally abrupt take a look and this is
right after debunking
another one of lou dobbs previous claims
says in which smartmatics technology was
banned in the u.s in 2020 due to
security weaknesses
or wrongdoing i am not i'm not aware of
any instances where smartmatics
technology was banned in the u.s again
it is
my understanding that outside of one
customer in los
angeles county smartmatic has no
presence
in the voting technology marketplace in
the united states
heading into retirement right to
commercial with uh with no word from lou
dobbs there
about how he has been making the
opposite claims
from that piece for about a month and a
half now since the election
so it seems very clear that this was
an attempt by fox news just to rectify
the legal problem they created for
themselves by
airing this stuff for week after week
after week now
it's interesting it's not clear to me
that this is a huge win
you and i see this and we immediately
understand
they've been making false claims for
what five six seven
almost seven weeks at this point six
weeks at this point um
the claims have been completely baseless
and
once it became once it passed a certain
threshold
the companies about which the false
claims were being made got lawyers they
sent legal letters and fox recognizes
that they've got to issue some kind of
legal
they've got to do something here to get
themselves out of legal hot water that's
what you and i see when we see this
unfortunately a lot of fox news viewers
won't understand
or even if they do understand that they
are not going to believe or give that
segment credibility
they give what lou dobbs has been doing
the last six weeks credibility but not
that segment
the saying is something like everybody
sees the headline
and nobody sees the correction uh one
week later
on the back page of the paper that's
basically what this is what this is
lou dobbs aired lies that he likely knew
her lies for the last six weeks
they got a legal demand letter from
smartmatic we know that's true
and we are inferring that that's why
that segment was aired
again without any commentary from lou
dobbs or him saying i've been one of the
people
telling you the lies for the last
however many weeks
maybe that is enough for fox news to get
out of legal trouble
but the viewers aren't going to be
convinced by it the viewers are going to
say
what lou dobbs has been saying for six
weeks is true i don't even know what
that segment's about i tuned out
once once it get cut away from lou i
thought it was a commercial i walked
away
and and grabbed a drink in the kitchen i
don't know if you guys remember
but back in 2005 dan rather on cbs news
aired some improperly sourced documents
about george w bush's national guard
service
and uh it turns out that the documents
they used
were not accurate and four cbs
executives
were fired for that and dan rather
resigned over that mistake fox news
oan newsmax won't stop repeating
the same baseless lies about the
election
and the penalty is that lou dobbs aired
a two-minute pre-produced fact check
without even acknowledging that he was
one of the
nodes of spreading the disinformation
that that very segment was debunking
even in the last 10 years the downfall
of seriousness in media has been
absolutely stunning
and is it better that lou dobbs aired it
than not airing it all
else being equal given the fact that
he's been spreading the lies is it
better that he aired it yeah sure
the reason he aired it though is not to
provide an alternative point of view
one that's fact-based it's because they
got a legal demand letter and it's
absolutely pathetic so
we are going to separately discuss
this bizarre outburst that donald trump
had on twitter over the weekend
but here i want to focus in specifically
on the
absolutely massive cyber attack believed
to have been perpetrated by
russia on the united states we've now
learned of a massive and ongoing
long-term cyber hack by russia with
evidence mounting more and more
that points to russia now of course you
can always say
we can never believe anything we're told
about who did it
but in that case you also couldn't
believe the things that trump says or
what anybody says so that's sort of a
non-starter argument if we want to
really evaluate this on on its merits
but the details as we know them right
now
are that five major federal agencies
were breached
uh according to multiple intelligence
agencies it's abundantly clear that it
was russia that did it
now multiple intelligence agencies
drafted a statement saying
russia did this and the white house
blocked the release
of that statement according to a senior
administration official
donald trump's secretary of state mike
pompeo even appeared on right-wing radio
show
on the right-wing radio show hosted by
mark levin
and said quote we can say pretty clearly
that it was the russians that engaged in
this activity
pompeo didn't get super specific but u.s
officials have said privately
it was the foreign intelligence service
the svr of russia
that's what sort of replaced the kgb
no one is suggesting china played a role
they believe it was russia it's not
hugely controversial
but donald trump goes on twitter and
contradicts
his own secretary of state pompeo as
well as all intelligence agencies
and says you know it could have been
china who did it something for which we
have
no evidence whatsoever donald trump
tweeting quote
the cyber hack is far greater in the
fake news media
than in actuality i have been fully
briefed and everything is well under
control
russia russia russia is the priority
chant when anything happens
because lame stream is for mostly
financial reasons
petrified of discussing the possibility
that it may be china
it may no evidence of that remember
there could also have been a hit
on our ridiculous voting machines during
the election which is now obvious that i
won big
that's not true making it an even more
corrupted embarrassment for the usa
so there are so many uh
elements to focus on here number one
obviously donald trump is not going to
hold russia accountable
in his last month left in office that's
completely clear but
he's also adding without evidence that
the hack
even including included more stuff
like voting machines during the election
so it's consider the stunning nature of
what he's saying
trump is distorting what has taken place
downplaying it and saying the fake news
is blowing it out of proportion
but then adding that there were actually
even more
things hacked than what the fake news
media is telling you
raising this idea that voting machines
were hacked which is completely
self-serving
merely to support his bogus vote voter
fraud theory so
at the same time he says this wasn't
really a big deal
but voting machines were also hacked
which nobody is mentioning which sort of
makes it sound like it's an even bigger
deal
than what is being reported because
nobody's reporting that voting machines
were hacked because there's no evidence
of it
and then at the same time sort of like
as the cherry on top
floating that it might be china when
nobody thinks it was china and there's
no evidence that it was china
now you don't have to be in favor of
attacking russia
neither as a left winger or a right
winger to merely acknowledge
there's really no reason to doubt that
russia did this and to concede
that there's no reason to think china
did do it because we don't have any
evidence that china did anything so
this is a few different things together
first this is
another example of trump opting out
of even a mild rebuke of russia that's
common we've seen that this entire
presidency
second this is donald trump trying to
make anything that is out there in the
news
to be evidence that the election was
stolen from him when he simply lost
plain and simple and then number three
this is trump again trying to criticize
china even when they've not actually
done the thing
he's talking about and fourth of course
it's donald trump focusing on entirely
the wrong things
as usual the response should be number
one
how do we deal with this thing that
russia did and number two
as the president he should be talking
about the fact that
more than three thousand people are now
dying every day from coronavirus
and he's not come out and talked about
it he seems done with coronavirus
and number three trump still hasn't
conceded and that's globally shameful
as well so trump silent on how to deal
with russia
silent on 3 000 coronavirus deaths today
silent
on conceding this election but very
loudly suggesting
maybe china actually did this hack it's
pathetic
it's dangerous it's a national security
threat and it is now an emergency to get
this guy out
and that's coming we are 30 days away
30 days away from donald trump being
gone and that's something that's not
just good for the country
that's very good for the world the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use the code pacman will get
15 off site wide
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so as i mentioned earlier donald trump
continues to just be absent and missing
as president his schedule is clear
every single day some days he'll have a
private event like lunch with his own
vice president
but trump has essentially disappeared
publicly there's really no president
right now
and fortunately we're getting some
leadership on the virus from joe biden
some leadership on climate from joe
biden who recently announced his climate
team
otherwise we would really have no
leadership at all in the united states
right now
but being missing from the public did
not stop donald trump from having a
globally embarrassing outburst on
twitter over the weekend
truly horrifying and shameful not
talking about the spiking cove deaths
now
excuse me surpassing 3000 a day not
talking about his loss to joe biden
still hasn't conceded but just
continuing to spread debunked and
baseless voter fraud
lies now we dealt earlier with the cyber
hack from russia and a couple of donald
trump's
uh tweets over the weekend were about
that but i've already talked about those
in another story
but the weekend was just rife with lies
and pathetic red herrings
and distortions from donald trump most
of it
focused around continuing to claim that
he actually
won the election trump tweeting a quote
from right-wing propaganda network
oan quoting an anchor there i guess
named christina bob
who said quote the lie of the year is
that
joe biden won now of course that's not
true and at this point trump will go
anywhere he will quote
anyone who will say something that trump
wants to believe
whether or not he really believes it i
don't know donald trump then attacking
his former national security adviser
john
bolton by saying quote what would bolton
one of the dumbest people in washington
know
wasn't he the person who so stupidly
said on television
libyan solution when describing what the
u.s was going to do
for north korea i've got plenty of other
bolton
stupid stories remember donald trump
ran on hiring the best people and he
hired john bolton and if indeed john
bolton is as stupid as donald trump has
claimed him to be
for years now then it really says
something about donald trump now
to be clear bolton can be stupid or
smart and be a disaster politically i
happen to think john bolton
is not a dumb guy but he's an absolutely
horrible reactionary i think trump is
actually wrong that bolton's stupid
i think bolton is a absolutely a
terrible person when it comes to policy
but i've seen no evidence that bolton is
actually
stupid donald trump then tweeting in all
caps simply quote
greatest election fraud in the history
of our country that's obviously untrue
and then donald trump retweeting a
conspiracy theorist named jim hofft
known as the gateway pundit who runs a
conspiracy website
who tweeted that quote simple math shows
biden claims 13 million more votes
than there were eligible voters who
voted in 2020 election now that is
completely untrue completely baseless
but it doesn't matter
when the president tweets it literally
millions of people believe it without
even looking further that's the real
tragedy of this
donald trump also retweeting some of the
silliest dumbest arguments
i've seen from a right-wing radio host
named kevin mccullough
for example one with a map of the u.s
by county which says biden supporters
seem to be really losing their minds
at how angry they get when you tell them
that biden won only about
16 only 16 percent of the counties
they get even angry about that than the
fact that they
are all supporting a cheater who's okay
with the cheating now
it's hard to parse the grammar there i
read it as as tweeted
uh but this is something that they've
been pulling out
frequently lately but it's meaningless
they they are arguing well if you
just look at a list of counties joe
biden didn't win that many counties
but of course most of the people are in
the counties biden did win what
the population of the united states is
in the counties that biden won
disproportionately counties vary in
geographical size
counties vary in population the
percentage of counties you won is a
meaningless metric and in fact
they don't even seem to know this but
part of what leads to gerrymandering
is the drawing of these bizarre
districts
in politically advantageous ways and the
fact that you have lots of counties that
are geographically large with few
people when you put up a map of red and
blue counties
it's part it's a similar distortion to
what we see by gerrymandering
different distor it's it's similar in
its nature it's not the exact same data
that is being distorted
uh but there are just dozens and dozens
of these retweets of
conspiracy theorists and others and then
this morning donald trump's sort of
capping off a humiliating weekend of
tweets
with the tweet big news coming out of
pennsylvania
very big illegal ballot drop that cannot
be accounted for
rigged election at least he's not
calling it a massive dump
anymore but it's still just as untrue
and as many of you
may know a week ago on december 14th
every state including pennsylvania had
their electors
vote pennsylvania has voted for joe
biden with their electoral votes
and that's it they've been teasing
things like this for weeks now whoa
big news out of nevada we're about to
get nevada uh
incredible what with massive dumps in
georgia we're about to take georgia
nothing is happening nothing is
happening and so
you know at a certain point trump will
go we're 30 days away
um we've talked about what happens to
trump's twitter
after january 20th right now donald
trump has
uh protections on twitter for world
leaders
where they are not subject to the same
rules that
you and i would be subject to when we
tweet it's uh
completely plausible that after donald
trump is no longer in power
uh he could be banned from twitter or
his tweets could even be taken down
we don't know that's more of an academic
question the big picture question is
does trump go quietly into the sweet
night and he gets out of politics and we
don't hear from him anymore
or does trump go as far as on the other
side of this
does he go as far as announcing his 2024
campaign
on the day that joe biden becomes
president and does he campaign for the
next four years
which would create dramatically
different media environments and
dramatically different political
environments for the next four years
we won't know um i guess until january
20th
but that will be the biggest factor in
determining what the next four years
are going to look like there is an
absolutely
insane criminal
disgusting immoral and depraved
series of allegations against donald
trump and his family
which are completely unsurprising if
you've been paying attention for the
last
four to five years a business insider
exclusive investigation has revealed
that donald trump's son-in-law jared
kushner helped to create
a trump campaign shell corporation which
secretly paid
trump's family and spent on their behalf
uh 170 million dollars
in campaign re-election money um it
actually spent more than that in total
but at issue are about 170 million
dollars 617 million dollars is the total
amount in play here
now we had rumblings about this story
months ago i've been covering this story
for months
you all seemed very interested in it the
number of emails i got about it was huge
i did a story back in july
called trump campaign laundering
millions to his own family
uh in september the investigations into
this were heating up and i covered it in
a segment called
trump panicking accused of laundering
170 million
dollars this is all part of the same
scam about which we now have more
specific
information so listen to these details
which are being presented by a source
familiar with this operation
to business insider the way this scam
worked
is that jared kushner who is trump's
son-in-law and also a white house senior
advisor if you can believe that
directed his uh sister uh his uh uh
his sister-in-law trump's
daughter-in-law lara trump that's eric
trump's wife got to keep all of it
straight jared kushner directs
lara trump and mike mike pence's nephew
john pence and trump campaign cfo sean
dahlman
to be on the board of this shell company
that they
created the company is called american
made
media consultants corporation and
american made media consultants llc
now that should ring a bell because this
is related to the name of donald trump's
former campaign manager
brad parscale's company and what they
did is they spent in total
617 million dollars that's about half
of the 1.26 billion that trump's
campaign
fundraised and some of the spending was
legitimate so the issue is not the 617
million
the issue is that about 170 million of
that money
is essentially laundered money as
salaries to trump's family and others
as well as a slush fund of all sorts of
spending
why did they do this the reason they did
this
is believed to be to avoid trump's
donors finding out
that a whole bunch of their money is
actually just being funneled back out
to trump's family and friends the next
step
is that if the department of justice
finds that this was done knowingly and
willfully
they would open up an investigation but
the big bombshell
is that several sources from the justice
department and
fec told the business insider
that there are investigators that may
already be looking into the campaign's
activity so there's a few different
things to talk about here number one
is anybody surprised to hear this if
you've been paying attention you
couldn't possibly be surprised about
this
number two i don't actually know that
trump's donors would really care if they
knew about this and what i mean by that
is lara trump was getting a hundred and
eighty thousand a year
you know a whole bunch of people were
getting a 180 grand a year and all this
all this money was being laundered into
companies held by trump's family and
friends
if you went with this information to a
lot of trump's followers
i don't think they'd be mad you would
say to them aren't aren't you upset that
for every 100 bucks you donated 50 was
funneled to this company
and then a bunch of that was funneled
like to trump's family just for going
around and doing interviews and
not not really doing much and i think
most of them would say no
trump has a great family and they're all
helping him win
and uh i i'm i'm hap the point is
i think a lot of trump's uh donors
would rationalize this money being
laundered anyway
now number three here's something
disgustingly ironic
the defense bill that donald trump wants
to veto
for ridiculous uh uh reasons
also contains a crackdown on the use of
shell companies to launder money it's
just like a side note
that's number three and then number four
pardons
you know how we've been talking about is
trump
going to preemptively pardon his family
members
jared ivanka whoever we weren't sure
why trump would think he needs to
preemptively pardon them well
if jared kushner is being investigated
for being part of this shell company
money laundering scheme
that would be a great explanation it
would fit very neatly into the puzzle
of why donald trump is reportedly
considering pardoning people like jared
kushner and others
look at what we've been able to find out
during the trump administration about
what they've done
imagine what will come out once this guy
is out of office
truly stunning and remarkable we have a
voicemail number
that number is 219 to david p
i have something special for you today
my live stream viewers may already be
familiar with this
we have a number of regular callers to
the show many of whom have been calling
in for a long time you've got troy york
you've got the san antonio troll you've
got the kansas
troll who hasn't called in for a while
we have our friend the eggman he's a
friendly regular caller
there's all these regular callers we
have a new caller
who we are calling re peter like peter
the name
peter ree hyphen peter because he will
just call
and call and call repeating the exact
same things over and over again i
introduced him to the audience two weeks
ago on a live stream where he called me
six times in a row with the same message
last week he called me 15 times in a row
with the same message
i don't want to deprive the tv and
podcast audience
from this so i've received 10 more
voicemails
just take a listen to this okay i'm just
going gonna give you a sampling each
voicemail is two to three minutes long
we'll just listen to a few seconds
here's the first one
david the gossip show i'm calling about
you're talking about this virus listen
to me very carefully you're not going to
understand this because you don't
you're just not that smart 99
of the people who get the virus survive
the virus
you only have only one percent out of
the people that get the virus
passed from it okay so that's voicemail
number one then number two
david the gossip show listen to me very
carefully this is about the coving
99 of the people who get it survive
it that means you only have one percent
of people that get it
that don't survive it 99
99 so that goes on for two minutes then
another voicemail coming in
oops sorry here we go i'm going to
repeat myself again
david the gossip cell and like i said
david you act like a little girl you you
belong in a dress and then
with some lipstick on it high heels the
corona virus okay it's actually from
china it's actually the china virus
that's worked because that's where it
came from
anyways 99 of the people who get the
corona
virus so that went on for three minutes
which is the maximum that our system
allows
call number four this is for david the
gossip show
about the coronavirus 99
of the people who get the virus survives
the virus
that was two more minutes here's
voicemail number five
i'll say it one more time david about
the coronavirus
99 of the people who get the coronavirus
they survive the corona virus that means
just a little over one percent of the
people who get it
don't survive the virus voicemail number
six
david the gossip show this is real
simple
we have forensic proof that
these dominion machines oh boy do uh
certain things to flip votes so now he
switches to dominion
voicemail number seven these
dominion machines we have forensic
evidence evidence numbers which don't
lie and then voicemail number eight
it's real simple these dominion machines
are designed for fraud okay and then so
there's five more
um can isn't it insane that this is like
my part of my job
um i don't know what to tell you my
friends
i don't i don't know what to tell you
but the the world is in rough shape
i think that any anything more specific
as a commentary about this
would really not do it justice the world
is in rough shape we've got a great
bonus show for you we will talk about
the new uk
strain of the coronavirus and its
implications we will talk about
uh a lot of other things make sure you
are a member and you will get instant
access to the bonus show
sign up at joinpakman.com coupon code
always available
fresh start to save a bundle
off of the membership of your choice
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
slash david pakman if you're trying to
quit smoking or vaping check out lucy
which is a nicotine gum developed by
caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save
20 percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman nebia is a
revolutionary showerhead that saves you
money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman